wait a second why why are you so tired
today and what's going on with your
sleep sleep oh how do you know well I do
know you you how do I know I abruptly
wake up at 4 in the morning every night
and I and I can't get back to sleep yeah
no i' I've definitely seen you hold your
breath but you you also snore right so
that's like indicator no no no it's
indic means have
nostrils right you snore I don't you do
a little bit I've Sor that what the [__]
are you talking about I you do it I have
never snored in life that's insane it's
have you ever queed I queed Bobby Bobby
I every guy has queed why the hole so
small you can't hear it sweetie the
little pocket of bubble in the penis
hole it
goes micro I have never snored a PE in
my life what are you talking about yeah
I breathe happy that literally is
doesn't make any sense why I like I've
never
coughed have you ever coughed I'm not
projecting there are people that snore
and people that don't if you can one
time in your life you've never done I've
never snored never do now let me let me
get a consensus of the room do you
believe not one time in her whole life
every night she sleeps right let me ask
you a question do you sleep every night
yes I do do you take naps okay every
once in a while yes okay I love it I
love it so one night do you think she's
ever snored yes raise your hands how
would you know if you're asleep exactly
thank you thank you guys I don't what
are you getting so about it's not a bad
thing no no no it's not a bad thing I
don't care but it's just there are
people that snore and people who who
don't have that problem I don't have
that problem I understand I'm sorry that
you do and you're really angry about it
I understand that I'm not fighting with
you I'm just saying that George pull it
up do all people snore Gilbert
definitely said well do you have any of
these symptoms K let's go through it
look I have I have I hold my breath in
my sleep for sure but it's I don't snore
like I've done sleep studies extens and
it's like more of a central sleep apnea
I mean I will say you are if anyone has
strong lungs and has no issues it's
probably
you strong lungs no but I think that I I
mean maybe if I was like fully congested
I didn't think I snored but every so
often somebody like yeah but all of you
guys are projecting your snoring
[__] onto me I just don't snore okay
I didn't I don't snore I've never heard
myself snore once you're very defensive
never heard I'm not defend well of
course no one hears themselves snore but
I have asked my entire family and lovers
and partners and people and they're like
being nice no that's hot privilege
they're just being nice why would they
why would they need to tell me
that hi I'm Kila nice to meet
you Bobby is under the impression that
100% of people on Earth snore have
snored in the their lifetime oh yeah
turn his on are you kidding me yeah
there we go there we go there go yes
there we go you think people don't
snore I think you guys are blowing my
mind you're about to punch someone she's
about to punch someone hit me no no but
no I'm saying she's claiming that not
one time in her whole life she's never
sored one time okay I will say this I
will say this you live
in thank you so much thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you I knew
that when
do you yes okay look at that nose RI a
professional snore look at that only
people that snore want to believe that
other people snore no people that do not
snore think no people that think they
don't snore also probably think that
their [__] don't stink no my [__] stin
no
no yes America yes I love so much USA
USA USA us I'm tired of your [__] lady
I'm tired of your [__] I the line here I
D the line here Jack can I just say
something yes you can yeah yeah I've
done a sleep study oh were we were we
there and what they say did you record
it not a [__] peep they said you do
not snore what did you do the sleep
study for then I have I hold my breath
trauma you're a lawyer are you a lawyer
yeah yeah I did a sleep study because I
was having these like um atic episodic
kind of like Wake Up full can't breathe
panic attacks in my sleep probably cuz
you stop breathing your sleep don't
worry probably of sleep apnea which is
snoring no not Central sleep apnea and
not panic
attack oh my God I I we need a sleep
doctor here anyway oh Let's Race each
other to sleep right
now I don't even understand tell the
rules tell me the rules I want to do it
tell the rules how about this all three
of us we sleep in a room room we record
ourselves we put up we actually never
going to be able to sleep with you two
[__] what the same you that would be
I am good sleep I really eat pizza with
you br I I can sleep good next to you
you know why there's no claim what a
claim you know who's not going to sleep
what me cuz you both
snore here's the thing it'll cancel each
other out oh right s exactly have you
ever recorded yourself they have apps
that you can record yourself while you
sleep well I've here's the thing okay I
will say this maybe if I've been very
congested and very sick maybe I'll
once go you said never snore but no
one's ever told me that I've told you
you've snored for 10 years not once have
you ever said have you
heard he's lying he's lying right now
you're [__] lying take an oath right
now lying you're [__] lying are you
lying will you [__] relax are you
lying will you [__] relax right now
Bobby don't tell me you're lying
please
hand yes look at me yes am I lying he's
not
lying I
have when I have when oh I don't know
October second 2016 what the [__] are
you talking about that sounds good he
also said he used to work at abian Fitch
that was a good lie and that was a
boldfaced [__] lie we all why was it
a
Hollister
God you're
good no look you got to record yourself
sleeping yeah because it'll pick up on
sleep talking as well which I do a lot
it is the best one time we recorded a
sleeping me and my ex and in my sleep I
said absolutely
horrific and then I said who are these
people did they get in for
free so maybe you shouldn't unlock but
you dream about like cover charge and
like if there people are coming to your
shows what you talking about I don't
know I think I've always wanted to be
like an intimidating
bouncer what I've done is I one time
made a mistake and took amban and had a
sleep eating um situation where I woke
up the next morning and I had a stack of
plates by my bedside and crumbs all over
oh my God I did that on the plane here